this remains an issue of consciousness
the narrative we thought we knew
is not the reality the narrative we
thought we knew is not reality why did
you think you knew the narrative
why could it be that you manufactured
the narrative because the narrative is
exactly what you wanted to promulgate
another day another media narrative that
has completely imploded about president
trump so
what are we up to now i mean we've had
the the entire four year long saga
of how trump was a russian caspar and
that turned out to be absolute nonsense
and we've had president trump as the as
the
scourge of the of all living human
beings all over the planet for a variety
of reasons usually those stories fall
apart we've had
a bunch of sub stories along these lines
okay here's the latest
the latest is the media completely blew
it on one of the biggest talking points
that democrats used
in 2020. that talking point because they
wanted to distract from the blm riots
was that donald trump
had cleared a bunch of protesters
peaceful protesters
in lafayette park in order that he could
have a photo up in front of a burnt out
church
okay now that talking point was always
pretty dubious because
the park police themselves had said at
the time guys we were clearing the park
because people were getting violent at
the time
that didn't stop folks from tweeting out
about the evils of president trump
clearing the park
so we have like a bunch of tweets from
all these people who push this false
narrative for example
npr politics tweeted out that day this
is june 1st 2020.
police in washington dc used tear gas
and rubber bullets on peaceful
protesters
to clear them away from st john's church
which suffered a small fire sunday night
near the white house
president trump then walked to the
church for a photo op
this was the way the media covered it
joe biden who was then running for
office wasn't president
of the united states yet he tweeted out
he's using the american military against
the american people
he tear gas peaceful protesters and
fired rubber bullets
for a photo for our children for the
very soul of our country we must defeat
him but i mean it when i say this we can
only do it
together that was joe biden back in june
2020 kamal harris
your current vice president then
candidate she said donald trump just
tear-gassed peaceful protesters
for a photo op she did that on the basis
of a headline from huffington post that
said
as the president spoke police deployed
tear gas and flashbangs against
protesters outside the white house
demanding justice for george floyd
daniel dale the official cnn fact
checker so many facts checked by
daniel's tale
his entire job was just to fire hose
a bunch of things that donald trump had
said wrong now his job is to downplay
anything the democrats
say that is wrong sort of tut them well
back then
he tweeted out this is february of 2021
actually
he tweeted out vanderveen falsely claims
the clearing of lafayette square last
june
happened to establish an appropriate
security perimeter from a riot as mob
no they cleared peaceful protesters out
of the way for a trump photo op the
narrative the intervene is mocking is
correct that was testimony
that was being made about what happened
so daniel jailed the official cnn fact
checker
getting it completely wrong because here
is the actual story there is an
inspector general
the inspector general for the interior
department and here is what they found
according to the washington post
when the us park police led law
enforcement officers into a crowd of
mostly peaceful protesters outside love
outside lafayette square
on june 1st 2020 including officers
equipped with chemical irritants and
officers on horseback
they did so as part of a plan made days
earlier to build a fence around the park
to protect officers
not to facilitate the visit minutes
later by president trump to a nearby
church
an inspector general's report released
wednesday concluded
the report also found that dc police
officers fired tear gas at protesters as
they moved away from the park toward
17th street
the park police did not deploy tear gas
on june 1 but did on previous days
and bureau of prisons officers fired pep
spray munitions from the park without
provocation during the clearing
investigators also found that the audio
warnings issued by the park police
before the operation were not widely
heard by the crowd and mostly
ineffective
the report by the interior department's
inspector general focuses on the park
police
and does not fully address questions
about the involvement of other agencies
or the trump administration the events
of june 1st
interior officials said they may not
have heard all of the discussions that
went on about the operation within the
secret service or the white house
but that those discussions did not
affect how and when the park police
acted
the investigators did not interview
secret service or white house personnel
the report found that preparations to
clear the protesters and erect offense
began two days before the park clearing
two days but the idea may have gained
greater urgency on the morning of june
first okay now they're just speculating
the washington post has previously
reported trump was furious at reporting
that revealed he had been taken to an
emergency bunker on the first night of
protests
the group agreed the park police and
supporting teams of law enforcement
officers would extend the perimeter and
gradually push protesters further away
from the white house and st
john's church which had been vandalized
the previous night by midday trump was
working with close confidence on a plan
to project his control over the city
by walking across lafayette square
but the the this had nothing to do with
what the park police were doing the park
police have been planning for days to
already clear
lafayette square park police officials
including then-acting chief gregory
monahan an
unidentified incident commander told
inspector general investigators they
learned around mid to late afternoon
of the president's unscheduled movement
to lafayette park both park police
officials reported they were not told a
specific time for the president's
potential arrival and that learning this
information did not change their
operational timeline which was to push
protesters back as soon as national
guard officers and the fencing arrived
both of which occurred after 5 p.m
monahan told investigators quote
i can tell you with 100 certainty
the secret service in the park police
timeline did not change
the entire day okay so the entire media
and the democratic party ran with the
lie that donald trump
forcibly cleared lafayette park in order
that he could have this photo op that
that's what this is about
instead park police cleared it because
they've been planning to for days
and as it turns out by the way there are
a bunch of officers who had been injured
in lafayette park over the prior couple
of days there are a bunch of officers
who there were 49 officer injuries
around lafayette park through may 31st
between may 25th and may 31st
49 officer injuries because park police
were according to the report being
pelted
with water bottles rocks and fireworks
but wait we were told these were
peaceful protesters just people who were
out there chanting for justice
and they were cleared because donald
trump evil donald trump wanted to walk
out and hold up a bible
at saint john's church nobody could
explain how these peaceful protesters
had burned a church
five minutes beforehand but the entire
narrative was never very good
and then the media just played it to the
hilt this was part of campaign
commercials for the democrats this was
joe biden
talking about it openly on the campaign
trail it was kamala harris lying about
it on the campaign trail
and again the media just ran with this
thing they ran with it
because it was beneficial to their
narrative which is that donald trump was
a fascist
the narrative was not going to be good
for them if it turned out that they had
been fostering
and backing and supporting rioters who
had injured
49 police officers or had been or
contributed 49 injuries to police
officers
and then made excuses for those people
and blamed trump that would have been a
worse narrative
so instead it was donald trump evil nazi
fascist
clearing the park of peaceful
flower-powered children
oh except none of that was true except
that wasn't true
and we'll meet the press acknowledged
that yesterday it was very very awkward
here was the here was kenzalanian over
at nbc's meet the press
having to make the awkward announcement
that yeah we kind of blew this thing for
a year
it doesn't second guess the decision to
clear the protesters it says that the
park police was within their rights
and this is controversial chuck black
lives matter is suing the justice
department in federal court over this
and our own garrett hake was there that
day and and reported if you recall that
the protests were not violent at that
moment until the police
moved in and caused violence that was
his direct bird's eye reporting chuck so
this remains an issue of consciousness
the narrative we thought we knew
is not the reality the narrative we
thought we knew is not the reality man
doesn't that sum up the entire
mainstream media for the past
30 years or so the narrative we thought
we knew is not reality
why did you think you knew that
narrative why didn't i mean the park
police said
at the time what the inspector general's
report ended up finding which is that
these two
events were not connected that trump may
have taken advantage of the fact that
park was cleared to go do the photo op
but that they did not clear the park for
the photo op
there's a difference okay but the
narrative we thought we knew is not
reality
why did you think you knew the narrative
why
hmm could it be that you manufactured
the narrative because the narrative is
exactly what you wanted to promulgate
and by the way this was the constant
drum beat it was the constant pattern
throughout the trump administration it's
the constant pattern today the nerves
that back the biden administration are
the ones they want to manufacture
just like the narratives that that
undercut the trump administration those
were the narratives that they wanted to
push
as hard as they possibly could
everything from trump
backs white supremacists to trump is a
russian catspaw
all those narratives are unbased in fact
does not matter they've continued to
promote those narratives over and over
and over again
down to by the way the idea that donald
trump is responsible
for the riots of january 6th as though
the people who write it didn't have
agency and ignoring the fact that he
explicitly called in his speech for
for people to be peaceful at the at the
capitol you could rip into trump's
rhetoric
without suggesting that he is
responsible for that any more than
bernie sanders is responsible
for a nut case going and shooting up a
bunch of congressional baseball players
again big narrative of last year
donald trump cleared the park of
peaceful protesters because he's a
fascist this was by the way exhibit a
this was one
a in the trump is a fascist case that
the left was putting out there
he's such a fascist that he sends his
brown shirt goons to go clear a park
of flower power children and then take a
militant photo op standing in front of a
church holding a bible what a
fascist except it wasn't true the
narrative we thought we knew as
kenzalanian says
turns out not to comport with the
reality and that is
how many times are we going to have to
see this before you stop believing the
media at face value before you
wait 48 hours before believing whatever
headline they are telling you
another narrative of last year that has
now been thoroughly debunked okay
remember that time that donald trump
kept talking about hydroxychloroquine
remember that time and the media went
nuts how dare he this giant orange
buffoon
mention hydroxychloroquine doesn't he
know about tough science
doesn't he know hydroxychloroquine
doesn't do anything
not only that but because donald trump
keeps saying hydroxychloroquine
some crazy lady in arizona fed her
husband fishtank cleaner and he died
now turns out they may have been
murdered but doesn't matter the only
reason they do that is because trump
kept saying hydroxychloroquine
over and over and over because
hydroxychloric and is bad
it's very bad okay now new study
out this week according to yahoo news
quote
a new study shows that the controversial
drug hydroxychloroquine first of all
the fact that it is titled the
controversial drug hydroxychloroquine
where did the controversy begin guys
seriously where did it begin it began
with you guys declaring that if trump
said anything it had to be false if
trump said wuhan lablek it had to be
false and it was conspiracy theory if
trump said hydroxychloroquine
is effective many doctors have said that
it is effective many doctors are
prescribing it
then it must be that it's false now by
the way we all knew
doctors were prescribing
hydroxychloroquine i know people
who got coveted and within the first
couple of days they got a hold of
hydroxychloroquine they took it with
azithromycin and zinc
and it did help their symptoms well now
a new study is backing this
okay there were studies both ways for
about a year and now it turns out a new
study suggests
actually a pretty significant effect
with regard to hydroxycholoquine when
you take it with the z-pack
the observational study published by med
rv rx iv
found that anti-malarial drug
hydroxychloroquine along with zinc
right this is what so many of these
studies were like if you just take
hydroxychloroquine alone
then it won't do any yes nobody said it
was going to do anything everyone knew
that the only studies that mattered were
going to be about hydroxychloroquine
which is an immunosuppressant and zinc
okay along with zinc and zethromyosin
the observational study found that
hydroxychloroquine along with zinc
could increase the coronavirus survival
rate by as much as nearly
200 percent if distributed at higher
doses to ventilated patients with a
severe version of the illness
the study's conclusion says we found
that when the cumulative doses of two
drugs
hydroxychloroquine and zithromycin zinc
were above a certain level
patients had a survival rate 2.9 times
the other patients
the study adds by using causal analysis
and considering the weight and
considering of weight adjusted
cumulative dose
we provide the combined therapy greatly
increases survival in covid patients
and that the more and that the the
hydroxychloroquine cumulative dose
of more than 80 milligrams per kilogram
works substantially better
these data do not yet apply to
hospitalized patients not on imv
the study was conducted by saint
barnabas medical center in new jersey on
255 patients
now remember if you mentioned
hydroxychloroquine and you said that it
was good
you would actually get kicked off of
youtube
if you said hydroxychloroquine is
effective
you would get booted from facebook and
youtube and twitter and they would call
you a nut
why because the narrative we thought we
knew is not the fact
just the same way the woohen lab leak if
you mention that you get booted off
youtube
if you did not simply repeat the experts
you'd get booted
don't trust people who declare
themselves experts without showing you
their
work if they don't show you their work
they are not true experts if they can't
tell you how they achieved a conclusion
you don't have to believe their
conclusion did you know that every
single like
creates one additional leftist tier that
is just science
[Music]